nanjing godrèche gérard darmon balle a
alors donc ça fait un an que vous avez
arrêté de tourner toute la france
regrette évidemment cette décision clara
morgane heureusement on a les cassettes
à la maison on allait on a les dvd à
gérard bodelet remus et voilà c'est bien
rangé alors la première raison de
l'arrêt de votre carrière c'est que vous
ne faites plus un couple avec greg
santoro votre fameux jules on y
reviendra d'ailleurs mais bon comme vous
vouliez tourner qu'avec lille avant que
vous n'êtes plus ensemble ou tourné plus
d'une première raison la deuxième raison
c'est que vous avez plus envie non c'est
une perte pour le cinéma je peux vous le
dire clara morgane
non mais sérieusement je détiens imposer
très rapidement un ouais c'est vrai d'un
succès fulgurant ouais j'ai une
notoriété assez rapide et notamment
grâce à vous parce que j'ai fait des
télés
c'est la mission du service public
non c'est la vérité j'ai fait très
rapidement des télés c'est ça qui m'a
permis de me faire connaître ce sens les
médias n'ont rien fait bien alors donc
aujourd'hui vous présenter le journal du
hard sur canal + en + genre quittez pas
quand même probablement le milieu
m'enfin non non vous regarder ce que
font les copines vous faites des
spectacles dans les discothèques tous
les week-ends un genre de strip tease
améliorer on va dire faut que j'aille
voir ça devant les journalistes il faut
vraiment aller sur le terrain je crois
moi même je comprends pas très bien et
alors vous avez écrit un livre il
voulait dire quelque chose et la bouche
ce qui a bougé et autres sans qu'il se
vend il est en fait il n'est pas
sacralisé après un bond énorme morgan
vous écrivez un livre qui s'appelle sexe
star et c'est aux éditions attaquant
mesdames messieurs
[Musique]
alice que je vous conseille gérard
darmon
merci ouais c'est en quelque sorte la
bible de clara morgane comparaison
possible
c'est une espèce de somme alors vous
raconter votre vie depuis votre
naissance à marseille en 1981 vos
parents coiffeur sur le vieux port
tout un poème déjà on voit bien
l'ambiance est quelque chose m bagnols
est là le web
oui et alors une enfance parfaitement
heureuse parce que souvent on dit les
filles qui font du porno elles ont été
malheureusement on a en france pas du
tout un bon parent très sympa le seul
choc de votre vie enfin j'ai trouvé ça
dans le bouquin c'est la mort de votre
grand mère c'est pas un truc bon c'est
lé bien toutes les grands-mères
finissent par mourir ce pas mais moi ça
m'avait plu d'être en est une autre
d'autres gens d'ailleurs depuis la mort
de cette grand mère vous continuez à
croire en dieu mais vous n'êtes plus
jamais allé ni au catéchisme clara
morgane ni à la messe non enfin chialer
ceci explique peut-être cela
permettez moi de dire d'un seul coup à
l'âge de 11 ans le catéchisme et la
messe voilà où ça mène
voilà alors l'âge de 12 ans au fait
pourquoi fait en photo ap après sa
capture en tout cas je serai ya un
langage du corps chez gérard qu'à
s'expliquer avec sa bouche
ok pour le week-end d'accord ok
attendant les quatre là
quoi gérard les plus que quatre
donc effectivement 12 ans les premières
photos la presse locale 14 en modèle
pour des robes de mariée dans une petite
gloire locale robe de mariée il freine
toujours des jeunes site très de 14-15
attendait serge paris nice hier sur
blain est ce que je peux voir ce qui
vient de se passer est ce que je peux
avoir un petit replay
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
merci j ai bien jours
et puis un jour clara morgane c'est le
déclic vous allez au manhattan qu'est
qu'un club d'après midi à marseille
halal et là vous découvrez j'étais
obligée d après midi mais c'est pareil
en a pas dit d'où vient l'argent et dans
ce club d'après midi donc à l'argent les
adultes une autre vie pour vous tant la
découverte de regard de moitié c'est pas
le même usage
découverte du monde des adultes et la
transition de l'enfance ase aux jeunes
adultes arrêtés
c'est infernal est ce que régis peut
venir s'il vous plaît régis mais je
publierai g100 deux noms et puis greg à
la grecque si notre chanson police y
santoro non si le partenaire de clara
dans les films il vous a vraiment révélé
à votre sexualité comme on dit chez dans
d'autres émissions et qui brille mais
voilà et la première fois vous faites
l'amour avec lui c'est une véritable
illuminations avec l'a7 à l'époque les
beaunois
donc voilà et là c'est là que ça
commence les histoires ce que jusque-là
bombe
et là vous partez pas pourquoi vous
allez faire du naturisme
mais au lieu d'aller faire du naturisme
chez les naturistes vous allez au cap
d'agde terme est plus grand aucun nom
mais au cap d'agde c'est comme avant
tout un grand centre naturiste un ouais
donc après la nuit
bon il ya autre chose mais là la journée
c'est un grand sont naturistes ma
famille là pour combien d'habitants cap
d'agde et et 25 personnes
il ya vingt-cinq mille personnes qui
buzz vous êtes allé non je vais lui
faire un contrat non le week-end non
mais bien d'armes
il connaît très bien gérard je suis né
au cap d'agde l'art au début j'avais 17
ans et demi à l'époque au début vous
pratiquez pas du tout l'échangisme
vous êtes simplement exhibitionniste
c'est à dire que vous aimez avec greg
faire l'amour devant d'autres gens n'est
jamais avec d'autres gens je parle du
début donc greg rapidement lui en
revanche il est conquis par les
chantiers mais l'échangisme c'est quoi
ces on se fait c'est instructif
il ya des couples qui ont besoin de
d'autres couples pour avoir une
sexualité débridée parce que ça fait des
années qu'ils sont ensemble pour un tas
de raisons il ya des couples ont besoin
d'autres personnes dans leur sexualité
moi c'est quelque chose que j'ai jamais
ressenti personnellement mais ça me
faisait rire de voir et là vous
découvrez que vous aimez aussi les fans
c'est quelque chose que j'avais en moi
depuis très longtemps
qu'est ce que tu veux dans tout ça c'est
quelque chose que j'ai toujours ressenti
en fait mais que j'ai pas vraiment
assumé très rapidement je voulais pas
trop y penser et cetera mais ça va j'ai
toujours une petite attirance vers les
femmes
oui voilà on l'a souvent comme un mois
voilà bombay la suite tout le monde la
connaît bah oui c'est la légende des
jambes de clara morgane on la connaît
c'est à dire quinze jours pas du tout
joël bois ovidie à la télé elle se dit
mais le cinéma porno c'est peut-être pas
mal voilà au même moment il ya eu une
solution utile c'est même comme france a
déclenché des vocations
au même moment il ya le salon autre
vidéo à paris elle monte avec greg salon
du jeu vidéo à paris il rencontre marc
dorcel
je me porte bien de mes fils je la
connais par coeur votre légende maurice
et toi vous l'avez lu avec attention
bien sûr pourquoi accord non c'est très
aimé ce livre là je fais très attention
c'est ce que je lis en entier oui ça m'a
bien plu c'est un bon jeu voilà donc une
belle soirée marie yourself danser sur
les tables et vous séduisez tout le
monde et à ce moment là marc dorcel vous
propose de tourner pour lui et vous
dites moi je ne tourne qu'avec mon jules
je me tourne qu'avec greg avant ça
c'était déjà après réflexion c'est vrai
que j'ai eu envie de me lancer dans
cette aventure avait pas avec marc
dorcel avec fred coppula vous connaissez
fred coppula des caisses vous avez
jamais au cinéma cocula comme copuler
oui voilà pourquoi pas la voilà donc
vous accepté le deal l'huile accepte
tout va bien vous allez donc tourné avec
friends
cet extravagant voilà c'est le début de
la gloire vous voulez tout
[Applaudissements]
car à bonal une carafe coup mais greg
lui comprend qu'il ne sera toujours que
le fiancé de clara morgane
ouais voilà et puis alors le succès ne
change complètement ce mec santoro face
est ce que vous dites dans votre livre
est alors il ya un truc que je savais
pas il se prend la grosse information
non parce que je savais pas c'est que
ses ardeurs bon ils foncent à toute la
journée
1 donc on pourrait penser que ça leur
suffit mais pas du tout avec le matin
quand il se réveille
la première chose qu'ils font sous la
douche c'est par évidemment pour
certains sur non mais enfin si grave
le matin en se réveillant très étrange
ça devient une drogue pour eux le matin
en se réveillant sous la douche bon
après ils vont travailler et le soir
quand ils reviennent bonsoir arrive soit
ils ont une femme soit il se paye une
prostituée est ce que tu peux imaginer
qu'un mec est souvent c'est les mêmes
que les gens ça devient complètement
obsessionnelle sur la main et ils
vendent tout le temps voilà
là là j'ai l'impression d'être dans le
coeur des hommes
c'est exact voilà le le film c'est ça
ben voilà et aujourd'hui vous êtes avec
fred coppula ouais il vous dit en
parlant de fred coppula c'est mon run
est un peu comme céline dion parle de
son run et je connais pas fred coppula
mais j'espère qu'il est mieux croiser
c'est quelqu'un de très tendre c'est bon
café les parrains dont le parrain ouais
ouais ouais donc vous avez une question
très personnelle
est ce que pour réussir dans le porno il
faut coucher est ce que pour devenir une
star de porno faut avoir du q est ce que
quand vous rentriez le soir avec grec
santoro à la maison vous aviez
l'impression de ramener du boulot à la
maison
non est-ce qu'on refusant la sodomie
vous privez pas les scénaristes d'un
ressort dramatique important est ce que
c'est facile d'écrire un film porno sans
sodomie maintenant je m'en fous
chef
c
alors maintenant car à morgane il va
falloir vous confesser interview c'est
le mot est très juste qu'on fait si
clara morgane avez vous déjà pêché par
penser par action ou par omission par
les trois à parler avez-vous commis le
péché d'adultère
une fois en turquie ça il faudra voir
une petite chérie des mariés oui mais
faudrait quand même petit pénitence pour
ça on en parlera après un certain du
confessionnal mais je mettrais bien une
petite pénitence mois pour avoir pêché
en turquie comme ça caraman regard
avez-vous à qufu accompli des actes
contre nature
non jamais car à morgane est ce que vous
avez dit des mots grossiers comme beat
ou couilles
quand une bonne santé ce monde tout ça
pour la grotte pénitence d'accord est-ce
que vous avez déjà été excité par un
animateur de télévision non est-ce que
vous avez déjà été excité par un acteur
oui
car morgane sexta
les corrections de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus